au sénat une douzaine de recommandations
vont être dévoilées par la mission
d'information d'évaluation des effets du
confinement et des restrictions
d'activités sur l'épidémie à partir de
10h bernard jomier le président de la
commission jean michel arnaud et roger
karoutchi les rapporteurs vont proposer
ses préconisations pour la réouverture
des lieux culturels fin mars emmanuel
macron avait souhaité cette couverture
pour l'animer alors en quoi consistent
ces recommandations bien les sénateurs
souhaitent encourager un système de pré
réservation pour les cinémas notamment
vont présenter des protocoles sanitaires
des dispositifs techniques adaptées au
musée au théâtre au cinéma
ils réfléchissent également un système
qui va associer les préfets et les
maires pour la vo verture de certains
établissements spécifiques
et puis il sera bien sûr question du
fameux pass sanitaires un pas le
passeport sanitaire mais bien ce recueil
de données sur une vaccination encore un
test pcr récents ils pourraient être
exigés pour les festivals d'été
alors il ne s'agit bien sûr que de
recommandations le gouvernement n'est
pas obligé de les suivre en tout cas ce
travail a été élaborée grâce à des
discussions avec des représentants du
milieu de la culture des données
scientifiques
et puis des retours d'expérience des
pays européens